schon bald schon wirklich sehr bald
könnten menschen auf dem mond leben doch
dafür wird baumaterial gebraucht das den
widrigen bedingungen auf dem mond trotz
jetzt haben fachleute aus norwegen eine
verrückte idee die das leben auf dem
mond in greifbare nähe rücken könnte
klicks um science fiction die gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos also montags mittwochs und
freitags abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
pixum ist teil von wir bilden zukunft
der bildungsinitiative vom freitag und
an diesem hashtag findet ihr weitere
spannende inhalte und morgen am 21 05
hat sich in diesem rahmen ein live
webinar dazu auf dem kanal von frey des
verbots auf youtube ab und zwar zum
thema warum wir auf die wissenschaft
hören müssen anders wenn nämlich blöd
der link ist hier unter me und in der
video beschreibung nicht nur die nasa
und die esa sondern auch china wollen
zurück auf den mond noch in diesem
jahrzehnt sollen wieder menschen dorthin
fliegen und auch für längere zeit dort
bleiben
eine bemannte nasa mission könnte schon
im jahr 2024 auf dem mond landen wobei
es gibt so ein bisschen zweifel ob das
geld reicht aber und möglicherweise dort
eine mondstation beziehen als erster
außenposten der menschheit auf einem
anderen himmelskörper dazu der nasa
wissenschaftler james green
geplant ist dass 2024 eine bemannte
landung auf dem mond stattfinden soll
dieses mal soll aber kein mann sondern
eine astronautin zuerst aussteigen
insgesamt wird das team aus vier oder
fünf astronauten bestehen zwei oder drei
auf dem mond ein oder zwei in der
umlaufbahn
das ziel ist die suche nach wasser das
auch für künftige mondmissionen wichtig
ist denn screen geht davon aus dass ende
der 30er jahre erstmals menschen auf dem
mars leben können das aufspüren von
wasser auf dem mond sein dafür ein
entscheidender meilenstein denn zum
einen ist wasser natürlich als
trinkwasser nutzbar
doch aus seinen bestandteilen sauerstoff
und wasserstoff lässt sich zum anderen
auch atemluft und treibstoff herstellen
im vergleich zu anderen himmelskörpern
eignet sich der mond als ziel immer noch
am besten
denn jupiter saturn merkur und venus
sind entweder zu weich zu heiß oder zu
weit weg der mond dagegen ist uns am
netz
und somit relativ einfach zu erreichen
und wir können einfach den fuß drauf
setzen
natürlich werden transportmittel
benötigt die astronautin astronauten
sowie die fracht kostengünstig und im
großen stil in den weltraum bringen
können doch diesen ziel entsprechend
raketen zu bauen zudem auch die kosten
zu senken kommen wir immer näher klar
ist es geht dabei um nicht mehr und
nicht weniger als der eroberung des
weltalls obwohl er uns also
verhältnismäßig nahe ist stellt der mond
immer noch ein großes rätsel für uns da
rund 350 kilogramm mondgestein wurden
bereits zur erde gebracht doch die
lassen nur noch mehr fragen aufkommen
das material lässt darauf schließen dass
der mond mal ein sehr starkes magnetfeld
gehabt haben muss doch dafür müsste
seinen kern eigentlich so flüssig sein
wie der der erde
doch das ist dann nach ansicht der
fachleute nun mal nicht weitere große
rätsel kamen erst gerade wieder auf ist
der mond vielleicht doch tektonisch
aktiv lange zeit galt er doch als toter
geologisch inaktive himmelskörper klar
ist jedenfalls dass er einst vulkanisch
aktiv war das zeigen viele läufer höhlen
große mit basalt gefüllte mond mehrere
und vulkane die sogar geologisch relativ
jung sind doch forschungsteam sind sich
einig darüber dass das mondinneren schon
längst erstarrt und somit erkaltet und
es keine aktive tektonik geben kann
doch schon die apollo-mission hatten
hinweise auf leichter mond beben
geliefert außerdem gibt es mysteriöse
steil stufen und faltungen auf der
mondoberfläche heißt also dass auf dem
mond noch immer viele rätsel auf uns
warten doch wie sollen die astronauten
astronauten dort leben und woher
bekommen sie das material das sie für
ihre basis benötigen klar ist dass jeder
transport von material ins all extrem
teuer ist und so tüfteln fachleute
weltweit daran die ressourcen zu nutzen
die sowieso schon auf dem mond vorhanden
sind die anforderungen an eine
zukünftige mondstation sind jedenfalls
nicht ohne die umgebung auf dem
erdtrabanten ist extrem und sie ist
lebensgefährlich und davor muss die
basis ihre bewohnerinnen und bewohner
natürlich schützen wer sich hier aufhält
muss nicht nur mit dem sonnenwind und
der kosmische strahlung klarkommen auf
dem mond ist man auch dem bombardement
durch meteoriten mehr oder weniger
schutzlos ausgeliefert
hinzu kommt es gibt kein magnetfeld
keine schützende atmosphäre und keinen
sauerstoff die temperaturen schwanken
extrem
zu 120 grad kann sich die mondoberfläche
durch die sonnenstrahlung aufheizen und
in der mond nacht und im schatten
dagegen herrschen temperaturen von minus
223 grad celsius das ist nicht so
angenehm ein haus für die zukünftigen
mond wohne rinnen und bewohner müsste
also vor diesen extremen temperaturen
schützen ein stück weit helfen schon die
neuen raumanzüge der nase eines der
beiden innovativen modelle mit der
bezeichnung exploration extra wie cola
mobility unit schützt die astronautin
astronauten aufgrund seines modularen
aufbaus aber nicht nur vor extremen
temperaturen die neuen anzüge
ermöglichen auch mehr bewegungsfreiheit
die astronautin astronauten können bei
der nächsten mond-mission wohl
geschmeidig über die oberfläche laufen
anstatt so zu hüpfen wie die apollo
generation und nicht nur das die nasa
ingenieur in christine davis zeigt bei
der präsentation wie sie sich in dem
anzug bücken kann und gegenstände vom
boden aufheben kann ohne dabei das
gleichgewicht zu verlieren eine extrem
wichtige sache für die erkundung des
mondes dazu christine davis die
mobilität ist sehr wichtig für unsere
arbeit wenn man einen stein aufheben
möchte wenn man ein wissenschaftliches
instrument einsetzen möchte dann braucht
man diese oberkörper beweglichkeit auch
die arme über den kopf zu heben
die zweite technische neuerung führt
dazu dass das system zur absorption von
kohlendioxid besser funktioniert das gas
entsteht bei der atmung der astronautin
astronauten und konnte von den
bisherigen raumanzügen nur bis zu einem
bestimmten sättigungsgrad aufgenommen
werden das neue modell ex em jug kurz
aber ist in der lage das gas nach außen
ins all abzugeben neben diesem neu
entwickelten raum und so gibt es eine
weitere neuentwicklung die wichtig für
die reise zum mond ist der orangefarbene
orion crew survival sud im worst case
beispielsweise wenn der meteorit die
außenwand des raumschiffs beschädigt
oder gar durchdringt könnte der orion
crew survivals tut das überleben der
crew sichern und zwar bis zu sechs tage
lang denn in einem notfall kann der
anzug die astronauten astronauten
stabilisieren beispielsweise wenn es zu
einem plötzlichen unerwarteten
druckabfall kommt doch wenn die kuh dann
erst einmal auf dem mond gelandet ist
braucht es eine unterkunft und im besten
fall auch sauerstoff der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa ist ein
entscheidender schritt in richtung einer
mondbasis anfang des jahres 2020
gelungen
niederländischen noordwijk wurde der
prototyp einer lunaren sauerstoff
verbringt installiert eine anlage also
die sauerstoff aus mondgestein gewinn
bei diesem verfahren wird der reguliert
zusammen mit einem salz erhitzt und
unter strom gesetzt dadurch wird der in
den mineralien gebundene sauerstofffrei
und genau das brauchen menschen die
lange zeit auf dem mond leben und
arbeiten sollen der sauerstoff der hier
aus den ressourcen vor ort gewonnen
werden könnte wäre nicht nur super für
die atmung der zukünftigen bewohnerinnen
und bewohner
es könnte sich auch für die lokale
herstellung von raketentreibstoff eignen
trägerraketen wie die ariane 5
beispielsweise nutzen eine kombination
aus flüssigem wasserstoff und flüssigen
sauerstoff ebenso wie die space shuttles
der nasa oder der apollo rakete saturn 5
möglicherweise könnte der sauerstoff
aber nicht nur auf gebundenem wasser
oder aus nun am wasser als gewonnen
werden sondern eben auch aus dem mond
regolith bereits apollo-missionen hatten
gezeigt dass proben von unserem
erdtrabanten 40 bis 45 prozent
sauerstoff enthalten allerdings in
chemische gebundener form
doch die neu entwickelte sauerstoff
fabrik theresa kann nicht nur das atem
gas aus dem reguliert extrahieren
durch die dabei angewandte schmelz plus
elektrolyse werden auch die mondgestein
enthaltenen metalle gewonnen dazu
alexandra morris von der esa wir wollen
herausfinden welche nutzbaren
legierungen sich damit herstellen lassen
und für welche anwendungen sie geeignet
werden klar ist schon jetzt die genaue
kombination der entstehenden metalle ist
abhängig davon an welcher stelle des
mondes die fabrik zukünftig ihren platz
findet denn reguliert ist regional
leicht unterschiedlich zusammengesetzt
eine einsatzfähige pilotanlage die auf
dem mond eingesetzt werden kann soll
nach dem plan der esa bereits im jahr
2025 fertig sein
dazu der esa materialforscher thomas
ghedini esa und nasa kehren mit
bemannten missionen zum mond zurück und
dieses mal wollen wir dort bleiben
deshalb legen wir unseren fokus auf die
systematische nutzung der lunaren
ressourcen vor ort so sind zahlreiche
fachleute weltweit davon überzeugt dass
es keineswegs notwendig sein wird das
material für die mondstation von der
erde einzufliegen
sie sind der meinung dass der mond fast
alles hergibt was man für das bauen auf
ihn benötigt um einen posten auf dem
erdtrabanten zu errichten braucht es
unter anderem türen fenster eine
startplattform ein mondfahrzeug ein
gewächshaus einen treibstofftank einen
druckbehälter für sauerstoff und noch
vieles mehr als möglicher baustein für
eine mondbasis könnte sich der lohn are
regolith eignen als basis dafür braucht
es zunächst einmal einfache steine aus
denen die gebäude auf dem mond aufgebaut
würden keine probleme würde es mit der
beschaffung des landes geben denn der
ist auf dem mond ja reichlich vorhanden
mit einem sonnen offen könnte man ihn
dann erhitzen dazu esa weltraum
ingenieur matthias maurer bündelt man
das sonnenlicht und konzentriertes auf
eine fläche so groß wie eine
ein-euro-münze entstehen bis zu 2000
grad celsius so also der plan um den
mond sei flüssig zu machen und dann
steine daraus zu formen
das tolle daran ist ja tatsächlich dass
es sowohl sand als auch sonnenlicht auf
dem mond in großen mengen gibt doch ist
dieses rezept sonderlich plant gleich
bausteine für eine mondbasis nicht viel
zu simpel forschungsteams konnten mit
einem probe ziegler aus der eifel zeigen
dass dieses einfache rezept wirklich
funktioniert der sand aus der
vulkaneifel ähnelt dem reguliert auf dem
mond und in dem experiment war es
wirklich möglich diesen mondstaub zu
erhitzen und daraus steine zu backen und
es gibt noch eine weitere idee die esa
tüftelt an einem konzept bei dem mit
hilfe eines 3d druckers aus dem
mondstaub eine station entstehen könnte
hierbei wird der reguliert allerdings
nicht geschmolzen sondern gebunden einen
1,5 tonnen schweren prototypen gibt es
bereits einfach eine mail schicken und
die teile die auf dem mond gebraucht
werden werden direkt vor ort gedruckt
klingt ein bisschen nach science fiction
aber tatsächlich wird derzeit erforscht
ob solch ein 3d drucker auch ohne
atmosphäre und mit der veränderten
schwerkraft auf dem mond fertig werden
wird außerdem gibt es bislang eine
weitere große herausforderung woher soll
das bindemittel auf dem mond genommen
werden das erst dafür sorgt dass das
material beim druck gut formbar ist und
nach dem erstarren stabil wird ohne aber
dabei risse zu bilden im klartext um aus
dem mond regolith mit hilfe des 3d
drucks wand teile herzustellen braucht
es wasser und
zudem ein weich machen das bindemittel
auf der erde kein problem hier wird
dafür nach tallinn oder pulli cabuk
salat genutzt und auf dem mond fachleute
aus norwegen haben für genau diese große
frage
eine passende antwort gefunden sie
schlagen urin der zukünftigen mond
bewohnerinnen und bewohner vor den urin
besteht hauptsächlich aus harnstoff und
wasser und eignet sich somit
hervorragend als bindemittel lieferant
und weichmacher auch wenn das zunächst
unappetitlich klingt konnten die
forschenden in ihren experimenten zeigen
dass sich harnstoff ähnlich gut wie
gängige bindemittel eignet einen
regolith analog als mondstaub ersatz
wurde dafür mit wasser und entweder
harnstoff naphthalin polykarbonat oder
keinen bindemittel angerührt dann wurde
analysiert wie sich das jeweilige
verdrücken und formen ließ und wie lange
es braucht um fest zu werden
wichtig war dem forschungsteam auch wie
stabil sich das material bei sehr
extremen temperaturschwankungen verhält
das ergebnis ist eindeutig die mischung
mit harnstoff erwies sich als weich
genug umgeformt zu werden dennoch war
sie auch stabil genug um danach in form
zu bleiben
dieses ergebnis ist vergleichbar mit den
eigenschaften der herkömmlichen
bindemittel noch nicht nur dass das
forschungsteam schreibt in seiner neuen
studie die harnstoff mischung zeigt eine
relativ hohe anfängliche kompression
stabilität heißt also dass die bauteile
aus der harnstoff reguliert mischung in
die stabil sind wie das mit gängigen
bindemitteln hergestellte material auch
nach dem erhitzen auf 80 grad und
mehreren zyklen von gefrieren und town
erwiesen sich die bauteile als stabil
ein wirklich überraschendes ergebnis
also aus norwegen das trotz seiner
einfachheit überzeugt das fazit der
fachleute ist positiv damit zeigt
harnstoff eigenschaften die ihn zu einem
vielversprechenden zusatzstoff für
lunare biopolymere machen ob der
harnstoff zuvor aus dem urin extrahiert
werden muss oder ob man nicht auch den
kompletten urin nutzen könnte müssen wir
noch testen die mondlandung der letzte
beweis neugier schon ein richtig richtig
cooler kanal also anklicken hier
anschauen und abonnieren und unterstützt
bittet die kanäle die ihr cool findet
mit einer kanal mitgliedschaft die
werbeeinnahmen sinken überall und hier
bei uns zb bekommt in die videos dann
vorab und ohne werbung also danke an
alles dies schon tun
bis dann
bleibt dran